er hat zuletzt sehr herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video leute ist es wird
hier mit den zwei schwerverbrechern die
kette schon zwar haben wir einmal hier
motto black schön dass du da bist habe
und xl da waren wir beide waren noch nie
eine video von mir jetzt schauen ich
habe ja bilder herausgesucht von netten
menschen die man von youtube so kenne
genau ich habe bilder von diesen
menschen rausgesucht aber irgendwas
dabei schief gelaufen ich habe irgendwie
ultra nah dran gesungen deswegen werde
die heute zusammen in dem video
versuchen haben so erkennen wir auch du
bild drauf ist verstört und der trainer
der heutigen runde leute muss im
nächsten video das er oder sie macht für
30 sekunden die personen sein die er
heute auch ist das übernächste richemont
und du bist im nächsten video 30
sekunden
ja ich bin jetzt fange an leute erstes
bild ist hier für euch und los geht's du
musst so schnell alte ja wieso es so
leicht
aber klar doch dass man muss sich
vielleicht für den nächsten jahren ja
aber das ist auch okay neues gekauft
werden was über die ersten punkte für
jana nächstes bild ab yamaha hat gestern
in stuttgart durch einfach ich dachte
der alte wird so leicht für euch ins top
acht mal auf die hautfarbe ja ich weiss
ich dachte nur der hass mails kommen ist
doch nicht weiter aber es ist auch
keiner von den stuttgarter bisschen
weiter nördlich ja nicht so weit ist
nicht so in unsere richtung von youtube
ich sage euch ein stichwort ok autos
therapieverfahren sehr lustig über
welchen scheiß ich kenne den namen aber
ich weiß
also ich hab mir schon oft so was von
den trends gesehen auch von wachsen luca
so gehören die performance hat das getan
aber ich musste über 5 wieder ausziehen
oder auch das 200 mio eur oder einbrüche
dort so weiß auch gar nicht ob ich
wirklich nicht mein erster gedanke war
wir können den jungen doch dieses dieses
griffen also ist ganz schön leon seien
wahrscheinlich ok 1 1 ausgeglichen
es gab wenig wie speedo ins coop ist
leider fakt halte es geht echt
ultraschnell man ja wenn sie also was
ist wie ein auge und ein hund da guckt
man ja darauf an dass er irgendwann die
ganze sache ihre grenzen man kann ja
auch nicht irgendwie youtuber appen bad
erkennen macht ok alles klar
22 du bist schneller ich sage ja da
machen weiter ich weiß nicht mal selbst
möchte das ist für euch gemacht da also
weiß dass ich zum beispiel schon lang
kein handy dabei ist das war das
bedeutet die bilder gäste abgab
obwohl red das nächste weise die abwehr
ist dass ich habe auch ein zweites bild
glaub ich gemacht für den fall dass man
sie erkennt aber was ich da drauf also
wer könnte das sein überhaupt erst mal
irgendeine mit den beiden leichen
leichtes doppelkinn frage findet ein
rundes foto patrick nicht gebeten und
frauke petry die frau eine frau alles
gibt das nächste welt ist von derselben
person leute und zwar bis jetzt nicht
mal etwas ist ja und es geht
bekannt haben soll so schnell warten
immer wieder sagt mein gehör nicht
bisschen schneller sein als logisch dass
du die verbindung ist sowieso ein
chiptuning auto nach links auf die
funktionen des trojaner nächstes bild
kommt potthoff uhr richtige allen
beteiligten persönlich die real life
project oder sowas wie derzeit aber
unter den augen
sie sehen schon recht alt auf ja ich
jetzt auf jeden fall bergmann
ich weiß ich werde schon mal getroffen
habt bestimmt gesehen auf irgendwie
youtube partie aber nicht ganz sicher
oh du hast so nennt aston led also der
datenmassen ok zweites bild das rehwild
vielleicht bisschen mehr natürlich tesla
3 2 1 1
[Gelächter]
na klar im frauen habe
nein ich gebe ich mein tipp er hat
früher im kanal mit zwei anderen
betrieben der kanal war einer der
größten wenn ich der größte youtube
deutschlands genau die ja als ob nicht
auch nicht ganz denn er kennt nicht
jeder so münster zu schlüpfen müssen
hierzu ein trojaner
[Gelächter]
wie immer drauf sind oder wenn es nach
dem vater sagte blättler damit steht es
4 2 für jana als maxime nächste video
etwa 30 sekunden konnte sein leute
direkt übers mitmachen beide sind
natürlich leute hier könnte ein kanal
abonnieren und hier kommt es zu einer
neuen folge von bugs das geht mir bist
du schön und lebt immer auf die hater
draufsteht ist auch keiner durch
vonlanthen